North Korea is run by porn king Kim
jong-il his favorite thing is watching
porn flicks he gets the attention of the
world and of the United States in
particular by messing around with the
development of nuclear weapons but doing
missile tests and the like and every
time he does he gets us he gets our goat
all my colleagues start running around
saying how dangerous this is and we got
to do something about it and we got to
stop it what he's doing is totally
unacceptable President Bush said that
for eight years and what happened he
developed a nuclear weapons he developed
missiles that are capable of reaching
for most of his neighbors for all the
threats so what were they saying what
were they saying what sense did it make
you can threaten the north if you have
the capacity really can the likelihood
really of carrying out that threat but
in the case of the North the leaders
there don't believe for a moment we're
going to attack them militarily and the
reason is very simple the reason we
don't attack North Korea is because the
South Koreans don't want us to that's
the last thing they want because even
though the South Koreans fully
understand we could destroy North Korea
and end the threat to them that before
we would complete that destruction the
North could totally destroy Seoul that
the capital city of the south so the the
South that would throw us out of the
country if they thought for one moment
we would start such a war in fact no
country would have us if we started in
such a war like that to have an ally
destroyed at the expense of destroying
an enemy so you know that makes that
makes no common sense we've got to look
for another way to deal with the problem
and one way to do deal with it right off
the bat is not to go crazy every time
then
North Koreans start rattling their
missiles or nuclear weapons we can deter
them we have deterred them they
understand full well that if they were
to make any serious threats to use any
of those weapons then we would have to
destroy them whatever the consequences
then you know the boss of that country
wants to watch his porn flicks he
doesn't want to get destroyed and look
people say oh no these crazy you can't
tell that I heard exactly the same
arguments all my career about the Soviet
Union and and the Chinese they say oh
they're crazy they'll fight nuclear wars
then we got we have to prepare to fight
nuclear wars the Chinese don't care if
they lose half a billion people well of
course they do you know it's just nuts
it's nutty thinking nobody wants to get
destroyed but they want to have the
security of those nuclear weapons to
deter us in in most cases to deter us